las autoridades ucranianas han estado
haciendo acusaciones durante semanas en
su intervención ante el parlamento de
países bajos el jueves volodymyr
selenski volvió a acusar a moscú de
llevarse a civiles ucranianos a rusia
por la fuerza de miles de niños
ucranianos y decenas de miles de adultos
fueron transportados por la fuerza al
territorio del estado ocupante por
desgracia no sabemos nada sobre el
destino de la mayoría de ellos las
autoridades de la ciudad sitiada de
mariupol dicen que más de 20.000
residentes han sido llevados en contra
de su voluntad a rusia una de estas
mujeres que escapó a la unión europea
describió su experiencia al washington
post los periódicos occidentales también
han publicado imágenes por satélite que
muestran los llamados campos de
filtración rusos instalados para los
civiles en el este de ucrania controlado
por los separatistas
el ministerio de defensa ruso ha dicho
que unas 420 personas han sido evacuadas
a rusia pero niega que esté esté
reubicando a nadie por la fuerza
naciones unidas dice que está
investigando estamos investigando las
acusaciones de que algunos residentes
mariupol han sido evacuados por la
fuerza ya sea territorio controlado por
grupos armados afiliados a rusia oa la
federación rusa mientras tanto el comité
internacional de la cruz roja negó lo
que calificó de terribles acusaciones de
estar facilitando las evacuaciones
forzosas al plantear el establecimiento
de un campamento en el lado ruso de la
frontera
y gwyneth facilite esto es absolutamente
falso el 60 nunca facilitaría ninguna
evacuación de civiles contra su voluntad
una segunda acusación se refiere a la
creación de un campo de refugiados en el
sur de rusia esto no está ocurriendo
en la cruz roja dijo que no tenía
información sobre deportaciones forzadas
esto a ambas partes a llegar a un
acuerdo sobre la evacuación segura de
civiles